this episode about real engineering is
profile plates curiosity stream and nabila
bundle tiel
sign-up now to watch the our long
version of this video linked in the
discription
if you were no pay attention
you need to go to or need the revolution
happening in the airline industry
the ds  on attempting to build bigger and
bigger er liners i eating a hundred and
fifteen passenger double decker
etro and the 600 and sexy passenger comes
seven for seven edgar
the beginning with her simply be every peter
of a new generation of claims
many more the ditch de maize  op this
iconic late post
you there benefiting from this change the
entire nature op air travel s change the
penny for you and your not
your local airforce jacket beautiful direct
flights to this tight lines and ever
before
at the price of those tickets er cheaper
than ever
connecting flight there becoming savior and
savior as the snow wide flame witch
over the place at the forefront of this
revolution the seven-eleven
cream liner eats v  ersie trillion dollars
pass on the future of the airline
industry
boeing sars from the poker table and post
aldert chips for or and olympic to a
radical new future and head of the
seven eleven revolution iced naomi hel
die r-line industry upgrades we had
future of  claims to be designed and
built
this is the breakdown or so nothing for a while
evans materials by be 50 5% of the 7 x
7 is partly made of composite materials like
carbon fiber reinforced plastics
sing-along the first commercial eyeliner
mee primarily
what is new age material
de 7  x 7 is rival only with the airbus
etro 50 ex chablis be introduced for
years after the 7th heaven
in 2015
so wire composite materials so desirable
for the airline industry
and semi-solid seven-eleven meet
most of the advantages
composite materials and made up of two
or more materials
t carbon reinforced plastics
dr compost of extremely strong carbon
fiber bound together by plastic race
carbon fiber middle of would be
tiny t  im fabrice of carbon is incredibly
thrones' intention on to five times
stronger it gives a stiel
and won or two bunch
this tiny manufacturer crazy solitaire
spider even this is an image of ie my
lord
bayside
i carbon fiber the carbon fiber is the
smaller and  just like a human hair
bacon pound in flex and separates very
easily if we don't the first by them
together with the plastic racing the form
is all the matter
otherwise they just for mac flow becomes
flexible factory there flexibility as
a factory is x oliebollenmix
composites soyuz  full of creating the
precise and each child curse of a small
with the rituals and designers composite
components can be made into almost any
shape and manageable in the post i
disadvantage of making large aircraft
components from
composites  or carbon fiber a plastic
resin it wecare fleek and pulled this is
required skills technicians and was a
noise criticism of the skill to the
production and quality does not work
together on this bore us army that t
play with us massive aircraft sections
die seven-eleven's fuselage so created
by rabbinge carbon fiber tape
impregnated with a plastic resin
ground in rotating mode of the views love
this machine precisely controls die
nuisance of the tape and the orientation
of the fiber is to ensure a way of
getting the most out of the car winst en
zo strand tourists in journal pressure
lead en de long journal pending lead
division life will experience
one of the problems with my [ __ ] met
it is that the press needs to be placed in
side and or in the cure dress in this hair
services plastic and critical is solid
kamp structure or in the site of
widebody chad eyeliner fuselage
er narsingh zak lycoming and this is or in
the lemmer went factor  en pads made this
way and requires mass absorbs
investment the building cost my dust
in large enough to fit de pers bos the
benefit's there will be the first en
usually usa the strand carbon fiber
provides previous generation r liners
it typically pressurized when i white
ribbon or rope are dirty that the same
height as mount olympus in washington
getting high enough that the lower pressure
would use your oxygen intake and your
stomach we expose sdr  insight is high
pressure and the outside this is om
compatible and x-axis you know the effects
glide bos stallions the seven eleven
strikers useloos
is can increase its internal and
pressure to an equivalent of 6004
twenty five percent lorin autoshot en
red therapy tri percent higher
impression die may not some black gloss
for the chose long ago in making the
journey of come on the ball and at the very
least the press and textile bobby version is
much
les frais thing is oh is never post my
father benefit of the stumps views  where
is that absolutely limes windows this is
the seventh heaven window and dsr windows
of together quizlet aluminum airliners
two there absolutely nothing in aircraft
mee  primarily of aluminum harry head
this large metal panels result in the
build up of stress-eating window am
sad as that stress offices snap t
davies round window this christ to
i see dimitri is strict but about
peter pressure cycles
tiny imperfections in the metro grow into
the larger trucks in a fancy much like
this large in an aluminum eyeliner what
they four lee shore a tape measure flying
greer we for in the three fixed or
disposed of guys like how later in
mcgregor is light short a disco
here something was still a problem for  the
seven-eleven tanks the composites roller
team energy to fiti
you can click dustin periodically up as many
times i like with carbon fiber since the
carbon fiber construction provide plenty
of perfect for the air line operators
two the cost views life is just one
mush of  per boat was able to eliminate
all joints and the already fascinated needed
to join them together sections de used
to be made up of want 1500 aluminum
bicycle president  i gather using for the
dvd fans in fasteners' there need is some
massive carbon fiber section
carbon fiber screen 2 regio already
mixedte viola slider be laminating
joint in fasteners' mix it a little later
ok
they were just read reviews you were
both the fuselage is also  in freddy
turned out to be aerodynamic because i pump up to
half a thousand bottles are already fads
about vindels joints and griffiths the
service imperfections middenplein
service graf and it costs you the firmware
flow increasing parasitic trike
composite materials help you to strike
in other ways to one of my favorite
things about s7 and s7 it is each child
winx
belt a structural member boeing is the
wind pair
the primary role is to resist the op
gods bending for securing flash is a
centilitre tonight i he she optimized to
resist pending shed the eyelashes of the
seven-  eleven
constructed of carbon fiber comb set of
ribs the structure members connecting the is
precious and that support the wind skin
er machine er  g will the aluminum place
that structure the river and forward whose
press for with rich froning between this
cold doing box and this form stem a load
bearing structure of the
wing like a level boxer feel between in
side the carbon fiber crops the game
provides towing  fantastic strand
strand is quantified at the force for
quiet completely invoice material carbon
fiber composites or another import
quality the mix too perfect before it
gains strength through maximum elastic string
there are two times die formation
elastic and plastic die formation
die least material we understand  park
in twitter original shake a free
download is loved
like and the last few post quinta
we per minute that shape and lives return
to original shape
load us screw
something guido land help
this is permanent time each carbon fiber
composites can continue the shape  this
try this plastic deformation such
er bon coin purse set wel aircraft
aluminum begins family di  e formation at
last and eyelashes and damit weekend and
carbon composite further the for those who cannot
be heard at the perm including formation
de and damic wickham I winx there super
flexible join flies the wingtips on the 7
x 7 I get tired at 3 meters
samsung glass  with an order ticket
certified pdf pdf free play nothing to be
able to handle 100 a fittie percent of
the plant absolute maximum xpect the lead
green flies crabtree second
and the joined a test the seven in
twenty seven and top is necessarily input
sex meters that i  great deal of en ding
de spice carbon fiber camps it ping
staff there an aluminum opinion xbox force
to the form the same valium of material
we critique lee 797 winx er nat so mc
escher aluminum gadget add this ability
to the standing greater pending
cloud engineer stem  i so 7
meaningless wings
with a much higher aspect ratio aspect
ratio is the region between doing span and
the meme court or with a high aspect
ratio of biology can win nice
glider we  l a lo aspect ratio copies
deltawing divider jazz international
airline there is an aspect ratio or that
like the seven not evening predecessor
the triple seven bosch pcm 7 s a knife or
aspect ratio it all level
this is what causes do not realize sevens
whose the  flex so much time flies
kapsets there action stiffer than
aluminum what the rebels see how it
stylight information hello die engineers
an attempt to greece in much higher
aspect reviewing a longer to roaring
that bent hear
bosch this comes with a view to benefit
the plains met the  highest aspect ratio
and gliders for and around power play the
highest priority is minimizing energy
loss to try this allows the glider
extended periods of
nourlangie details of aircraft typically
have aspect regions greater than furby
and this aircraft ragged tight
penalties as a result  or word extra
this is the dry kasbah ait mixing of the
high pressure such under the wing the flow
pressure er apeldoorn vo  rming for the cz
the wind up by spreading the area of the wind
ver a longer span to minimize the p
essure that drives so mixing and doing
tip and thus minim
ze the energy loss to the boards norma
ly fire aspect ratio wings flori
turnova leads for a remembered glide
this is intention was for ethylene
the nothing that storage space for few days
left or jolly profile min slow range and
won on the primary goal 7 x 7 is 2 and
fint long range aircraft
capable of allowing airliners on a
new roots that we our team  in possible
thankfully modern clean slate 7 x 7
youth a new can take you far for the
supercritical euro for all there for a
sip of something like this
a republic' magic design de shadows
and gentle girls on the upper and lower
service and this is a super critically
the leading edge the land there with a
large array that is the tab is relatively
groin boot and the long version has the
strange crosby park
this bird of prey has much more useful in
journal valium
dans  toot plants leading edge and
larger fitness deficit region
helping soflo in tunnel though a problem
associate there with high aspect ratio winx
that supercritical wind was fresh testing
parnasse of a modified tf micro cedar
and duke in reeleezee the simulations in
design levels between the experimental
plant sleek  winx with the 7 x 7 post
increased in journal valium is not mine
assen developed the supercritical win
close developed this to delay the onset
of jacqy formation over the winx
when travels over owing who er a
top excel there something this means the even
though the planet  self hobby traveling
alone the speed of sound die over doing
my bridges and create a shockwave
the shockwave die crisis lift en coaches
and increase and dry
expert try this cold wave trike a
plant don't plant the fly polo the speed this
curry sauce the speed is cold radical
mark number
that supercritical wing was designed to
increase the critical mark number
de flat top of the supercritical wing
least  die er so to excel there is as
much as a word about i was i for
of course this causes elacin lift focus
dat fast moving er is causing a
drop-in pressure on top of the way to
compensate
supercritical air force it is concrete
preacher under  not doing what causes
and increase of pressure
where to comment share this increasing
pressure
so to effect the critical mark
number the large array that is on the leading
edge
in crisis the lift greater and higher
ankles on the fence
this is because there's pulled east
follow  the tiger turns the narrow radius
leading edge with course earlier whistled
attachment and set the large array that can
be read so flew separation
this euro save changes continue i
he she traveled talent of doing
twisting the carving in computer
calculate precision optimizing the wind
shape to  be as efficient as possible and
composites provider die engineers the
conference with die chips could be my
feet shirt
the skin is simply laid down a  nemoon
arms de triplane once again you don't
have people in the shape each and every
time you want to recreate the telegraph
de fogers of the wing and even professed in
specific patterns to tailor the
stiffness of the wind
in different areas
this means de winden  forms x i read the
seventeen service engineers wall decal
like a child speed
so the winship absolutely changes during
flies together won't it en tip for
speed
this is cool arrow classic tailoring
and is the fore forms of cities of the
earth and oracle engineering today the
seventh  heaven also features and novel
device design tattoo reviews turbulent
flow over the tale of the aircraft to try
to flow increasingly sexist in aerodynamics
laminar flow
various at praisen lesbian en is
characterized by fleur players flowing
smoothly over each other in nice orderly
layers
laminar flow is predictable  and no new
york and so to create significant'
raik turbulent flow is far more coming
it still very little is known a  bout how
to protect ip's behavior it is very
difficult to control
because of the formation of small board
cisco daddy's in de flow make in de flow
highly raik turbulent flow serious and
higher floofy lesbian en Kies
significant increase in greg en cruising
speed
editer die 5%  or the speed of sound
turbulent flow is auto melee unavoidable
pants and worked minimizers
boeing less developed at technology that
helps him delay and control the
formation of turbulent flow colt hybrid
laminar flow control dvl sander
implementation of de technology experts
this technology is capable of producing
viewer  why is my chest scent die percent
en zo companies and keeping the research
extreme toilet products keep their
competitive advantage
grease wino in de lilies and early
nineties nasa and boeing big and invested
earring i suction system de 757 the
hooray in ruins 3 leer er dat  is the layer
of very slow moving there task links to the
service or moving object that was out sites
kin prem  er ball toe en asked annie
perforations too small for de no
qoraishieten see my [ __ ] the premium
service as belt at the waist holes
clear of the brie
is one of the many challenges we the
technology that is older and in er skin read
and attached to a  lower tension system
that is connected to the herbal plant
one shot honor of the pantry layer of
there form long the plant service by
doing this decotruss i showed oil and
reviews the size of the turbulent flow and
internal reviews to run the place
there  is no space for the deposit system
in side-wind the seven-eleven
forest of maui to know it is in side of
the oriental and vertical tiles however
the place of the presence of the time
lords so try one mystery tami
the light lead no  information available
online i will of dirt in windows
planet campus the script plenty of
judges
for the dashcam boots to wine these pictures
who i train together in the
composition for material sometimes atmi
15% of display  is titanium that moshir the
standards that temium is an expense of
material so much was the farragut recent
user about aluminum
aluminum is typically corrosion
resistant win bad so to speak
win this place in direct contact with
carbon fiber campus it's something
strange on the
die aluminum  start piece red
incredibly quickly
something about carbon fiber breaks
aluminum the action rise and fall apart
carbon fiber is like aluminum script i
love this phenomenon is calkar little
corrosion en de schaepkens van two
materials de rat dissimilar
elektriek potentials or nobilities er placed in
contact with en  electrolyte maxalt
be
even look at galvanic series with
quantified materials nobilities
weekend see the graphite is very noble
on different of de l'escale wal
aluminum is kreuzfahrten guys
win this occurs
en electric tent show forms between
the two materials
the course the tutorials does a reasonable
trance  and ajax must results in the and
ozpin is in the w  ei
dit effect is may the force one the
service of de moor nobel material the
cathode is very large in comparison to
de les noble material die en oud
safe for example of carbon fiber campus
het servaas en together using aluminum
fashion earth to avoid is corrosion die
engineer is not the pick and material
closer to care ben in the calvados series
aan de closes suitable metal was die
trainings
this has been a few choice of cost in
my invoice boeings production closet was
hired and it sales price for quite some
time opinion they were  making and loss
and each aircross oh this is very typical
renew airliners and sorry die and
my faction tooling cost take time to
recruit and company slide boeing
typically spread is cross-over i period
of time on each plein instead of just
having in master negative al  a cheese
in when
puppy cost was 7 x 7 once the clinic
that song capelle and costs money deferred
costs for expected to reach twenty five
trillion the renovation l  iever reached a
break even point and something small oh
for the costs of the invoice an icon
the sales price in comparison
the bore triple seven reached called us
to call
touring refrigerator is fast as possible with
essential the boeing reviews the costs
production and hi other  reads was the
illumination or draws a imparts
where possible the frame a round head
with windows for example when i feel i
made out of sight and i do or change to
aluminum the special coating that
prevent grange was some parts de war en
richly titanium uw change  the campus something
with the door frames what a trial with
sources to make the men invoice in
process for titanium less costly
way with each other used an aircraft start
af is large blocks of metal the had to be
seen them into their final share these
results in  the tone of voice the metal
if the metal grudge live the w aircraft
men invoice is butts for this with
touch met something called by te flyeren
show and if you a source of incr  eased my
affection costs costs cost the boeing
tackles but collabo reading with
northcott a in detail temium 3d
printing company
well
week in 3d printed metal parts' is
something beautiful titanium 3d printing in false
in bodybuilding that is multijet there hung
readers
research use high-  speed extra imaging de
via live weapons green this process and
found i love of imperfections
the cherry hide the power i
put you the two resulting in very fence
necessary the trucks and even bubbles for
a cozy boys in the metal
discreet heart with a lot  of micro
imperfections and imperfections showed
decrease live svt breaks crashed for
week a party life and materials
misjudged straight pipe load of a s
and nick
bush meat is the magnitude of die
alternating stress to the reactions and the
number of cycles is five of those
access for traditional machines die
temium
fair something like this
price for 3d printed parts and looks
like this
3d printed parts simply much modern  r
because of the tiny imperfections lorsque
les word to improve this
instead of using laser sintering met
powder northcott developed in
revolutionizing peter this wire beast with
electrical printing systems for
training
it a manager with 600 frames per sec
and cameras for quality control
these 3d printed parts  of the machine
down in twitter of shape
reducing the total touch an i used by
2050 15% and distant printing with is fifty
toe and 100 ans ferry of the power
printing at this process results in
the first ever and vs certified 3d printed
structural components and  the fresh flow
in the boeing 757
display is drury innovative
titanium podsnap which oil material
bowling worked and removing of the plant
construction tc van kost
barber wind forms and important part of
the seventh heaven swing
where i was laid down in finn strips on
doing service this  is not a typical
design choice freerk red wings and once
again
i was influenced by so 7 x 7 scampi's
en construct  ie pico's
composite materials and has conducted
carbon fiber is a great kan doctors and
problems arise because of the past i
crash in finding them together as this
reason is an insulating material
preventing the position of the treasury oh
it is a knife or problem for planes
necklace  gp lighting is humming
regards
want studie calculé de de lightning
strikes occurred once every 3 hours of
line between 1950 and 1970 5 is 7 x 7 was
struck by lightning bolt taking off from
hydr on online ding in india for those
two the for the sex as  we found in the
views like
if there will on your sister feeling
the plant survive and has flown pak
landing fires with emergency procedure support
bos compensate for to belgium de disco
still damage is europa en de euro per
process is more complicated than white
aluminum
however this  tried for having my words
has the electric reed is well runs
smoothly long the service in the square
and access and make as an expert interview
tanks and chose an e  xplosie this little
often student was neeson come in the
early days of the airline industry
time flies two we for we struck by
lightning
while at flow and holding a red wedding
for online in storm to pass and
philadelphia international airport in
1960 7 is left wing fuel  tank explodes
crossing de klein the barrel out of
control
to the ground in flames
since its the aviation sector has
implemented rigorous safety measures and
lightning protection test
when shore and accidents like this could
never happen again early 7 x 7 left in
front of the hall with hairdressers trips  to ensure
the electrons harry pad of loog
resistance alan de service of doing
insuring they wouldn't travel 20yo tank
and causes berk while also preventing
exactly the celebration damage to the hood
subscription
fashion there is where co2 and insulating
material to stack trays idea of
ing  down the metallic fashion er
interview dyke and the even fascinates him
for fit with compression ring
scenes england  ' to eliminate hentschel
spark locations across backups and sharp
edges finally so 7 x 7 is a nitrogen
in nursing system that fills the tank
being nike ignition side we
would accept
boeing the center or two on these
protections in the carving knife hour
removing the hairdresser match and setting
caps
foot scrub concern and critical is an
attempt a few tip 3 en de night's king
and nursing system and the other safety
measures the expense of features is
not yet for composit scorpion
other materials which shows
the leading edge of the wing  and tl the
telephone and part of the engine cooling
mainly of aluminum or mud with
the leading edge or two with the
aluminum also our campus the track
impact resistance wel campus sm xtreme
die hi friend de can be spruce
up impacts search words words
which  most commonly cabinet the leading
edge of the win or on the edges with our
rebooting the form of in suit with a
reviews johnson fraction in voice sharing
and scampi's the word aluminum bleeding
edge is especially will beneficial for the
purpose of the icing
the chance there is a god
thermal conductive if you have ever flow
on a very cold day you may see I
drew spray flowey the developments on
the square
this is  the icing flirt
I see this mixture of glycol and where there is
something not this package mosplein a couple
of the icing themselves on the ground
the seven ex even a fact with
external power okay serious is a new
tribe of the icing system so 7 x 7
users electrically gieten blankets
wall thickness the service' covers budget
able to cast service of the wing and
reports or prevent any information on the
leading edge louis traditionally ice is
prevented by extract in facility of
the engine and piping is then of urban
areas such as the leading  edge swing your
eyes image upgrades severely interview
with the winx operation this transvaal ibl
energie and woe of the ages and increases
fell can sometimes also require i
computer  network of showing and x-axis
must ahoy and a crisis complex
deconstruction and maintenance
via electrical inspection system is the corn is
efficient sd i deleted blieberg system
has no excess energy is last preventing
there two die atmosphere and it as reviews
strike
stx as schools for the  blieck er on the
lower east side oprah winfrey you run
the 7 x 7 is definitely the first commercial
there liner that is a lemonade the display
air system music you technical challenge
and require the i complete redesign of
several systems
end and entirely new engine in her
nek video more ardougne to explore the
incredible engineering bihain de power
systems on the 7 x 7 x plore in défense
mens in the jets engine and the overall
system architecture der luyden 7 x 7 to
become the most efficient longer a
gelliner
ever made
we will be  releasing day video here on
youtube charlie puth if you go to face
it already an apple a free or if you
like me and like this app can watch
slimmer video'  s we've created this
special our long version that combined
boot videos and it is extra information
the thick fits into every one on the youtube
course iphone color the longest boot on
these videos in the description for those
of you already subscribe to mobile
or if you  have yet to start supporting
the channel their you can sign up frutti
nabila and curiosity shrimp part
for just for see 17 ever here that just
overcame dollar and mouth
bos there won dollar if i pull antique
impact on this channel pico's weekend your
uncle and insisted  ever gaming platform and
dawkins as the freedom to create where you
live how i won't give you were a fan of
this channel nebula is the best place to
watch everything you make one possible
we upload and videos early to mobile
and advertisement sector of the
you can also get exclusive content from
was Lekker logistics optidee series of
you can learn about my life for youtube
in lowspecgamer excellent nabila
exc  lusieve podcast
genesys where you can learn the story of
how i got my job and engineering to
start china
love
was that youtube channel and dat 20 your
accountant in need what youtube
the item details uploaded on may think
that she can remember why you what  you
could be for greater youtube channel
little overcame dollar mont this is by
far the best way to support this channel
and you'll get something in return met
access to boot nebula en all of the word
winding document reese andreas the
screen like this fascinating biography
en neil armstrong live mary joe harris
en for you can sign up to this amazing
deal by clicking on this button on
screen right now or if you are looking
for something has to watch right now
form and plans or  you can
watch sewer sciences video from the
insane biology of dragonflies